need motivation watch a top 10 with
belief nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome that number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you as well you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so get ready to endure pain
ignore the haters and overcome fears
with Dane lock and my take on his top 50
rules for success volume 3 joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one in Germain many years ago I had this
conversation with my mentor and he asked
me the question Dan what do you think is
the number one quality of an
entrepreneur and I said many many things
I said talents and I said team and I
said a good idea I said many many many
things and no he said the number one
quality of a successful entrepreneur is
this and that is the ability to endure
pain for a long period of time didn't
talk about the Ferrari didn't talk about
the big house paying for a long period
of time is that you what are you willing
to give up what price are you willing to
pay to accomplish success to build your
business I could tell you any successful
entrepreneurs that I know almost all of
them experienced pain for long period of
time before they accomplished even just
a little bit of success
rule number two ignore the haters I
still get like comments YouTube like
basis right
I look like psy I look like you Joel
every day I get that that's okay that's
okay they're not who I want to in fact
right I said remember if you have a
million people watching your your
content ten percent don't like you 100
thousand people going out ten million
people watching my content that's a
million people not liking me the only
people like and because he was so the
rock and blunt and provocative right
like it's right so people hate me really
hate me like it's not like oh I can't
don't like this hey yo God like you die
like it's like very like direct stuff
right because it's - it works them right
yeah by the same time keep watching my
stuff for it's hilarious hours I think
like I've haters everything like same
hey common you suck watch all my video
you can see like negative comment right
there same dude immediately keep on to
my stuff rule number three overcome
fears you see what holds a lot of people
back is fear fear of success fear
failure fear of making a mistake think
about it before you do something you're
saying to yourself well what if it
doesn't work or what if or if I lose
money and what if what if I make a
mistake then what happens what if I
don't know what to do what if I can't
figure this out there what if what if
what if what if what if it does work you
see always remember fear is an acronym
it stands for false evidence appearing
real
it's nothing more than a made-up story
in your own mind so do you have your
fearful ego holding you back
rule number four start with gratitude I
thought that happiness is a destination
if I get to someplace I make certain
amount of money if I own certain amount
of things they
and I would be happy then I realized as
I am now older and a little bit more
mature and a little bit wiser that it's
not happiness it's not something that
you seek it's something that's already
within you but a lot of times we are
blocking it so you think about why
people are depressed why feel unhappy
usually it's because when their
expectation because you know it's our
expectation of how your life should look
like where you should be at this by this
point and your reality when your
expectation and your reality when they
don't match up you get depressed you
feel very very unhappy because this is
where you are this is where you think
you should be and the bigger this gap
the more unhappy you are so to be
happier you can do two things you can
either lower your expectation so then
your gap is not as large example you
want to make a billion dollars and
you're making now a thousand dollars a
month well you will feel very unhappy
very very much unhappy because today
this is where I should be
it is why man well below expectation 100
bucks you low expectation I'm gonna make
a 102 dollars right now you're making a
hundred ok now you're not so bad I've
only shown you two dollars right that's
okay
so you get lower expectation
which is what you can do or you can now
change the reality how you can shorten
the gap right that's what I achieve at
us how do you match how could you push
and challenge your reality to match to
expectation you could do that or the
other way that I look at it is this when
I start the day with attitude of
gratitude coming from a place of giving
coming from a place of love coming from
a place of I have enough right I have
enough because whatever your goal is
you're getting the same thing but just
more right you have one car you want two
cars you want to because but it's the
same thing if you're not grateful you
don't appreciate what you have now
you're not gonna appreciate what you get
then so I am grateful with what I have I
start with that while achieving what I
want right I'm grateful with what I have
Wow achieving why I won NYX when I start
from this place I just find that I'm
much happier I like today I'm a happy
guy believe also if you want to have
more confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join are in the
description below that's a problem with
young people you're not good at anything
oh good no tell me the truth you're not
good at anything after you practice
martial you develop this natural self
confidence not cockiness but you develop
this natural self-confidence remember
this your business is always a
reflection of you rule number five have
a big vision to be a great leader to
inspire other people here's what I
believe in that you must have something
that it's bigger than yourself in order
to inspire people in order to enroll
people into your vision example if you
talk to your employee talk to your team
member and you say hey you know what
this is why we're doing this so that I
could make enough money so that I could
retire or so that I could build this
business so that I could be living the
10-hour week or twelve hour work week
to be a lifestyle entrepreneur see that
doesn't inspire anybody because it's all
about me me me me me
so to be a great leader to inspire other
people you kind of have a vision that is
so big there's so compelling that other
people want to be part of them right
it's like imagine you are the captain of
this ship and you're saying hey this is
where we're going we're going to this
island and it's going to be great and we
are going to to have all these great
things when we get there and that's like
wow you know people look at that say
yeah I want to be part of that but I
want you I want to join this journey I
want to I want to join alongside and and
be alongside with you and maybe there's
some obstacles there will always be
challenges there will be waves in the
ocean but that's okay I want to join you
and help you to fight along and be
alongside with you going through this
journey so I believe very much their
leader needs to think about what is your
mission rule number six understand the
industry don't start a business if you
don't understand the industry I always
ask this question before you start any
business and that is and I'm asking you
right now why'd you and why now if your
answer is all I just want to make some
money you're gonna fail why you and why
now what qualifies you to be in this
space right now not what I just saw on
Facebook oh that sounds like a good idea
this person this guy is making so much
money doing this I should jump into that
to know why you and why now in order to
make money in any industry you have to
understand the industry if you don't
know the industry first you have to
learn the industry let's say you want to
go open up a restaurant now I'm not
saying that's a good idea but let's say
you want to open up a restaurant
well isn't a good idea to just go work
at a restaurant see what's the
day-to-day operation like what I'd like
to to work in a restaurant before you
open up a restaurant so you have to know
your industry rule number seven don't be
the know-it-all person see when I was
broke I thought I know it
I don't need to read books I know what
I'm doing I was studying all these
businesses and guess what none of them
worked because I thought I knew what I
was talking about guess what I didn't
know she okay you don't know she seemed
to know it all always thinking they know
everything keep doing the same thing
again and again and expect a different
result that's the very definition of
insanity rule number eight build
work-life integration when you are an
entrepreneur right when you are running
your own company it is not something
that you do is who you are
one is who you are this doesn't turn off
there's no such thing as oh well you
know I don't want to work on weekends I
take the two-week vacation when you're
entrepreneur you're going all the time
because I always say that's why I don't
watch sports I don't need to watch
sports to get some chips through
entrepreneurship it is the most
competitive sport in the world because
when you watch any sport game guess what
you're playing for 30 minutes 60 minutes
whatever how much amount of time well
with entrepreneur 24/7 someone somewhere
is trying to kick your ass
somewhere someone somewhere they try to
steal your customers they are trying to
grab market share it is 24/7 so we have
to be thinking about how can we be
better how can we serve our customer
better how can we deliver more value
this is ongoing
there's no work/life balance or how to
separate the two
I don't meal my life around my business
I built my business around my lifestyle
preference so right now I'm going
somewhere I'm gonna do an interview
I'm filming I'm creating content I'm
connecting with you
that's integration when I'm traveling
I'm traveling for business at the same
time I will be travel for pleasure take
a few days off it's integration versus I
work at work I work at work oh my god
man I can't take this no more I need to
escape from this I need to avoid this I
need to go somewhere and then from there
I need a totally unplugged so don't
bother me for a week
oh man I took a vacation I'm Tina Beach
doing nothing and then come back oh my
god man you kind of dragging your feet
now I gotta get back to work it doesn't
work that way so I will find a time in
between how do we charge my battery now
in my case I like movies so I don't need
to take you know two weeks off in order
to recharge one of these maybe JD and I
we go to watch a movie two hours out
with Josh a good night's sleep
I'll recharge and back at the game rule
number nine get out of your comfort zone
things are fine you know I don't I don't
need to be there ambitious but that's
the problem your income zone is your
comfort zone your comfort zone is your
income zone when you get complacent when
you get comfortable you are not growing
remember when you're not growing you are
dying so do you have this Eagle that is
holding you back right now and what are
you gonna do about it
rule number ten create a legacy what did
you realize during your platform closing
career or speaking career like that's
all I'm gonna focus on impact and with
serving while that two incidents that
happen so first is when I hit 30 years
old
there one day I got in the morning
our tears coming down my cheek yes I
know what's crying a little while I was
crying I would just have this depression
coming over me which I'm then I don't
get depressed right it doesn't happen to
and I realize I've after that point away
I lived my life that I've grown a
company I made a lot of money but I
wasn't being who I wanted to be right
because I was 20 to 30 years old like to
see for that you see today more pearl
but you can see from time to time I have
that yeah right but I was about that
before yeah I was all that like that
right oh it's that anymore okay wasn't
shooting very very people very nice okay
wasn't just arrogant because I felt so
I'm so smart and I'm smart but I it's a
wrong attitude right so when I hit 30
years old when that happens depression
and that's when I realize okay I need to
look for something else
so remember like my both mom and dad
their pearls right and my pic then my
mentor is like extreme movie yeah so
right the first so I thought that was
the way you have to be to be successful
I didn't have any other role model I
have five father figure so from there I
tried to be big then okay like do what
he does and all that and it wasn't and I
I got to a certain point but I wasn't
happy so that was first turning point
right okay I don't realize I went to
deep dive in terms of spiritual work in
terms of even well it's just work I did
a lot of studying and I found mine kind
of new path right so that's number one
second is 20 my father passed away we're
not chasing a deal that was just chasing
the next success and I thought that I'll
make him proud well in fact he passed
away I can like that a mess mr. chance
that's one I realize that's not what
life is about because when my father
passed away I'm like okay it's it's real
like the people closest to you they
could take a leave
and then now I started asking what's my
legacy right what what I want to be
right do I do I want to keep going I can
make a lot of money which I'm very good
at making money no problem mm-hmm right
but then I would think about one thing
they also when I went to the Bruce Lee
grave in Seattle right you know I was
there every five minute there's someone
going there every five minutes after all
these years every five minutes from all
kinds of background for all kinds of
crunchy countries people bring flowers
and all that I'm like that's a legacy
right that's a legacy he's an iconic
martial artists actor that lives through
all this age right and I'm like I'm not
saying like I'm boosting here I'm just
saying that Wow right so that inspires
me that's when I shift my focus into
rule number 11 build self-esteem here's
the number one success secret that no
one talks about and no one shares this
is something I've learned from my mentor
Dan penny at the fifty billion dollar
man self esteem is the foundation of our
success now I'm not talking about
arrogance I'm not talking about pride
I'm not even talking about just
confidence I'm talking about self-esteem
now what is self esteem self esteem is
something that your parents didn't give
you think about when you're growing up
when you want to do something when you
want to take some risk what do your
parents what do your friends what did
they tell you you're not trained for
this no one in our family is an
entrepreneur or you don't have enough
education or you don't know the right
people just be content right be happy
with what you have or hey son I want you
to be successful but not too successful
I want you to think about what is
holding you back the goals that you have
that you want to achieve why don't you
do what you know deep down that you are
supposed to do why don't you take that
risk why don't you stop that business
what's stopping you because you lack
self-esteem now the next question you
might have seafood an how do I build my
cell
of esteem let me give you a perfect
example let's say you have a friend of
yours and he tells you all the time hey
man that's let's hang out and say okay
you know what let's hang out let's go
grab a drink let's go you know go for a
hike every single time he says ok let's
do something he would cancel on you and
there happens again and again and again
so let me ask you a question if there
happens all the time how would you feel
about this friend this person would you
trust him or her not so much the reason
you don't have high self esteem because
you have a lousy track record meaning
how many times you promise yourself that
you're gonna do something but you don't
how many times you make promises to
yourself and you don't deliver you don't
follow through on those promises and
guess what
when you do this enough for enough times
for enough years you have low
self-esteem because you know you know
yourself well yeah I guess I want to do
that but I'm not gonna follow through
I'm not gonna make it happen and that's
why your self-esteem is low you don't
even believe in yourself little things
big things you make a promise to
yourself and you deliver rule number 12
be driven successful people are
incredibly driven how driven are you now
I'm not talking about you being a
nightmare to work with or or bullying
other people I'm talking about you
pushing yourself to get results it's
your personal drives that turns your
ideas into actions into results it is
your personal drive that keeps you going
when things get tough it is your
personal drive enables you to bounce
back from disappointment from setback so
how driven are you or are you lazy do
you procrastinate do you put things off
you see for the first five years of my
career I didn't take a single day off
I was working 10 12 14 hours every
single day's for five years
strict why because I was driven I was
driven to provide for my family
I was driven
to prove other people wrong and today I
am driven by my mission how driven argue
rule number 13 don't be negative you are
walking down the street and some of you
here and suddenly you see a red Ferrari
just drove by what's the first thought
that comes through your mind comment
below
no filter no edits just comment below
what's the very first thought that comes
to your mind
my guess is chances are he's an [ __ ]
who does he think he is so cocky so
selfish
probably a greedy bastard actually you
know Polly's not his money anyway it's
his daddy's money or if it's a lady's a
woman oh that's a gold digger right all
these negativities guess what that's you
judging other people my question to you
is how do you know how do you know it's
all made-up stories in your mind right
and you say oh he's not that good she's
not that pretty
he's not that smart you're judging other
people you're projecting your own
insecurities your own values on the
other people how do you know that man is
not a hard-working man how do you know
he's not a good husband how do you know
it's not a family man how do you know
he's someone who's worked 20 30 years to
get to where he is at this point how do
you know you judge you come to your own
conclusions before even talking to the
person you see how your mind works how
are you gonna be successful how are you
ever gonna become rich if that's the
image that you have for people who are
successful rule number 14 do what works
for you you see this on social media
very often people talk about the morning
ritual or waking up very very early in
the morning because all successful
people they all wake up in the morning
so do you actually need to wake up early
early in the morning to be successful
that's one of the problems with people
don't know how to filter advice now are
there a lot of people who are successful
who wake up in the morning absolutely
but are there also a lot of people who
ask
successful who don't wake up in the
morning absolutely right but it's this
propaganda on social media that people
focus so much on that success has to do
with your habits what you do on a
consistent basis and you have to know
what time in the data you're the most
productive for some people it is early
in the morning where there's no
distraction these people are still
sleeping and you go through the day
maybe you go work out maybe you do
meditation then you plan the day
that's fine for some people they don't
wake up early they wake up whatever time
and then they work late at night they're
more like a nail
I'm Malik Ania I find that I am the most
creative late at night when it's quiet
when there's no noise right when there's
not a lot going on I find that that's
those quiet times sometimes become my
thinking time so that's what works for
me I think you find what works for you
doesn't matter whose advice you're
getting from it could be before me could
be from anybody else but you have to
know yourself enough if it doesn't work
for you if you get up in the morning
you're like oh my god I'm so tired
you're sleepy you're exhausted and for
many many days and Dutch just like it
screws up your biological clock then it
doesn't work for you and that's kind of
one thing that I gravitate towards Bruce
Lee's martial art as you follow my
working on my martial audits that Bruce
is always about you finding your own
path that's why he said his martial art
style is not a style it's a set of
principles you define what works for you
I've saw what it's so useful reject what
is useless and what is eventually on
your own
rule number 15 practice martial arts the
fact I like martial art because it's
it's not a physical
sure it's a mental sport that's right
right because a lot of time well you can
play tennis all you can play golf play
all that it's nice
yeah but martial art is a sport where
they say I'm hitting a heavy bag Yeah
right
doesn't matter how good you get and
you're competing with yourself that's
right and it's all about the limiting
eliminating your own defect I could fill
a punch mm-hmm well I can 12 pints we're
gonna hit it with speed if I can hit it
with power that's all that I need to
learn and practice and do all that stuff
so I love that part of it and it's a
never-ending challenge it's never good
it's never good enough you find someone
that can do it faster bigger like
stronger for sure I love that there's
always someone that's gonna be better
than and I can go super philosophical
right way I cannot how about physical
like it just goes off an esophagus it
and I can do that extreme and I love
that crazy deep dive of life and
philosophy I love that aspect I love it
rule number 16 don't make excuses you
can make money or you can make excuses
but you cannot do both an excuse is
nothing more than a well planet lie you
see the excuses ego sets well I can't
afford it I don't have money right
oh oh oh that's too far oh that's too
too difficult to I don't have enough
experience it's always I can't I can't I
can't oh I don't know
how you see you could have a million
excuses why you cannot do something
you only need one damn good reason why
you must do it rule number 17 don't fear
failure one of the things that holds
people back that I believe is fear fear
of failure I want you to ask yourself
this question what would you do
differently if you knew you couldn't
fail would you take more risk would you
be more aggressive you don't need to be
afraid of failure I'll give you a
perfect example when I was making an
offer
when I was driving people to take an
action and investing in themselves when
I'm speaking to a group of audience
maybe a hundred people 200 people 500
people on a good day I might have 10 15
20 percent of the people in the audience
they will take action and they will
invest in themselves so you would say
wow that's a 20 percent success rate yes
that is as 20 percent success rate but
the other way to look at this is
basically I fail even on a good day 80%
of the time I would get a rejection 80%
an audience would say no in marketing
when you are running traffic when you're
doing your marketing online let's say
you get a three percent conversion
meaning a hundred people this is your
website three percent will take action
they say your conversion of three
percent ninety seven percent would say
no 97 percent would not buy and 97
percent would not take action well guess
what you have a 97 percent failure rate
you see anyone who achieves any kind of
success experience failure on a
consistent basis rule number 18 overcome
adversity whatever you're going through
right now I know may be very very
difficult and it almost finished at the
end of world and you're only the world
right the only the world I want you to
imagine that you are now three years
five years maybe even ten years from
today and now you're looking back and
what's happening right now and you ask
yourself some of these questions is this
bad as I thought it is what can I learn
from this I know it's very difficult you
think I not learn nothing from it
there's nothing I'm not even this no
what are some lessons you could you
could take away well some the value
given this right this is going to be the
most difficult one what could you be
grateful for that this happened to you
and you're like oh come on come on then
there's nothing to be grateful for this
accident happened this emergency
happened or something tragic that has
happened like just nothing that could be
grateful for I know but if there is
something you could be grateful for what
could you be grateful for ask yourself
those questions suddenly that would give
you perspective and when you come back
to reality where you are now to looking
at scenario okay if it's changes from
now maybe it's not as bad imagine even
things that happen to in the past
the adversities that you experienced in
the past think about that it could be
two three five ten years ago back then
that felt like the end of the world that
felt like it's the worst thing that's
ever happened to you back then now
looking today looking back back then how
do you feel about those incidents my bet
is this it's not as bad as you thought
and you learn a lot from it and probably
you find something that you could be
grateful for that
that adversity turns out to be one of
the greatest thing that's ever happened
to you rule number 19 mastered the skill
of communication back then when I was
going to high school in Canada in
Vancouver I had no friends right because
I was very much an introvert I was very
shy because I couldn't speak a language
when I first arrived to this country I
couldn't speak a word of English so I
was very afraid to talk to people of
course when you're afraid to talk to
people no one will listen and I remember
I would try to communicate very various
even simple language simple words with
my classmates and they're like what what
it's a part of me and I would have to
repeat the same thing three four five
times and because they just won't listen
and eventually they pretty much just
lose their patience they're like I don't
I can't understand your myth I can't
understand we're talking about so they
don't want to talk to me because they
feel it's it's it's very troublesome for
them right
so I know for a fact when you see what I
do when I'm now communicating with you
that I can speak I can command an
audience an offense you know from all
over the world that communication this
is a learnable skill it is a what
it's a learnable skill this is something
that you can learn I could go from
someone who's a total introvert shy no
one will listen to me to now that people
would listen to what I have to say right
rule number 20
be yourself number 10 the fake ego
have you ever met someone that you don't
know them but the minute you meet with
them they just have this weird kind of
vibe that you don't trust him or her or
they feel very fake then you feel like
oh my god they're just so fake they're
so superficial that you don't make that
connection that they are not genuine or
have you ever met someone that's just a
minute you meet with them you make the
instant connection and then there's that
trust that says that bond that you feel
this person is sincere
the fake eagle maybe that's you maybe
that you're very good at putting on this
mask you're very good that in one
circumstance you can be this person in
an other scenario you become a different
person and then here you become another
person and before you know it you've
done it for so many years you don't know
who you are anymore
you don't know which one is the real you
which one is the real you you've lost
yourself be yourself everyone else is
taken be yourself I will rather people
hate me for who I am then love me for
who I am not so don't don't use the fake
eagle you don't need it to be successful
rule number 21 build great habits
successful people have great habits
unsuccessful people have lousy habits
habits like smoking drinking taking
drugs watching too much TV
you see successful people are where they
today because of their habits habits
determine 95% of a person's behavior
everything that you are today everything
that you accomplish in the future is
determined by the quality of the habits
that you form what I've found that is
the very best people have the best
habits you see successful people are
simply those with successful habits
successful habits could be getting up in
the morning meditate reading exercising
regularly how many of these habits do
you have rule number 22 don't make
excuses I'm just an introvert I'm not
good with people and I'm just like it's
okay I don't like to talk out just like
that right you used as an excuse you
used that to stay in your own bubble you
used that to stay in your own shell
that's what believe it or not I was a
very very shy person I was an introvert
I was the kid when I was going through
high school I had no friends I didn't
want to talk to people because I
couldn't speak the language we're so
afraid even now sometimes when I go to
meet a lot of people I still sometimes
have that little bit of awkwardness it's
normal but I don't let that hold me back
I know if I want to be more successful
if I want to be rich I have to get
outside of my comfort zone I have to
overcome my shyness that's how I could
do what I do so don't use that your
personality as an excuse to hold you
back
rule number 23 redefine failure when you
are successful you actually experience
failure much faster much much more on a
daily basis but it doesn't matter
because the ones that said yes that's
what builds your business that's what
helps you to achieve your goals so from
now on I don't want you to think of word
failure I want you I want you to be
placed what failure from from your
vocabulary from your mind instead use
this word feedback it is feedback not
failure is simply feedback from your
customers from your prospects from your
clients from the marketplace Hey
maybe this offer is not what we want or
maybe the price point is not something
that they are comfortable with or maybe
the way that you articulate you'll share
your message you communicate the value
it doesn't resonate with with the
prospects of the marketplace every
single action that you take you're gonna
get some now failure you're gonna get
some feedback then you're gonna be able
to pivot you can make changes to your
approach you're gonna learn something
from it
so next time you're gonna do it just a
little bit better and knowing this
there's more feedback that you get the
faster you get those feedbacks we will
talk about bail forward right bail fast
forget fail fast it's getting feedback
fast
knowing hey this is waste of time this
doesn't work no problem forget it now
let me try this and let more feedback
maybe don't like the feedback but that's
okay it doesn't work all right no I
don't need a waste more time and then
BOOM hey the marketplace my customers
they like this perfect that's good now
that's the feedback that you want rule
number 24 influence and persuade and
communication skills come in many forms
I'm talking about writing their email or
writing their social media posts or
conducting the meeting or speaking
one-on-one speaking on the phone talking
with a prospect or even speaking to
large groups of people all those falls
under communication skills one of the
things that I did that change my life
early on in my career is I joined
Toastmasters to hold and develop my
public speaking skills and what's also
learning for a mentor to develop my
cooperating skill which is communication
in the written forms how to use words in
print to persuade influence somebody so
all successful people they have this one
thing in common the ability to influence
persuade inspire other people
rule number 25 don't care what others
think do you worry
how people perceive you you know you
want to do something but oh what would
people think of that what would people
think of my action even deep down you
know
that's the right thing to do but you
don't do it because you have
other people's opinions ego you let
other people's opinions stop you from
doing what you know is the right thing
those people they could be your family
it could be your relatives they could be
your friends it could be your high
school buddies it doesn't matter it
could be social media you're uploading a
video you're posting on social media
you're making noise you're getting
attention suddenly you get a few haters
guess what you stop people who don't
care about you haters and trolls who add
no doubt in your life and some keyboard
warriors some losers
post a comment like oh I guess that
hurts my feeling and you stop doing what
it's right you stop doing what is gonna
make you successful
stop stop worrying about other people's
opinions it's just a opinion system
doesn't matter
critics haters haters gonna hate it
doesn't matter you do what you know is
right rule number 26 overcome adversity
when you're going through the
adversities when you're going through
all these things you only put some
distance but an other thing that you
could do is talk to someone there has
already gone through that one of the
things that I'm very fortunate because I
have a lot of peers
there are successful mentors people
around me that whatever adversity even
today that I experienced that's that
happens right which I still do that ooh
maybe like it would feel I would feel
frustrated I would feel like maybe I'm
not so sure what to do
but I will talk to someone they say talk
to a mentor and he will laugh as a yep I
experienced that 30 years ago 35 years
ago and he's what you need to do and
they would share with me my perspective
suddenly I don't feel so bad because
what happens is when you experience any
kind of problem any kind of adversity
you think you are the only one in the
world that's experiencing this not true
I can tell you from experience a lot of
people have experienced the same things
you're much luckier at least you have a
YouTube channel that you could come
visit and see
and get information and get insights I
didn't have any of that back then rule
number 27 learn Mark Cuban which three
hours a day Bill Gates reads at least
one hour per day I go to two to three
books per week for years now I'm still
constantly learning all the time I'm not
just talking about reading a book it
could be listening to a podcast talking
to other successful people getting
coaching from your mentors but
successful people we're always learning
and growing and we never stop one time I
was asking a very successful person out
for lunch it's been very successful for
so many years it's made merger and
acquisition space he's had multiple
successful exits so multiple companies
at a very young age when we sat down and
we're sitting across each other and when
we had that meal the first thing that he
did is he pulled out a journal and
taking notes and started asking me
questions learning I was the one who
wanted learn from him but it turns out
into a learning session that he's
learning from me I'll never forget that
because you see the more you know the
more you will lies you don't know the
less you know the more you think you
know rule number 28 don't let your ego
hold you back if you want something done
you got to do it your self well they'll
never do it as good as the way that I do
it oh I don't trust him or I don't trust
her if you want something done you gotta
do it yourself what you're really saying
is I don't trust other people that is
ego there's a form of ego that holds you
back
because nothing great is accomplished
just with one person
it requires other people requires
teamwork so the do-it-yourself ego this
is probably one of the most common evils
their whole most people back their hole
most entrepreneurs back that's holding
them back from going to that next level
because they are control freaks
they have this massive massive
do-it-yourself Eagle that's holding them
back
rule number 29 play it smart my whole
life I've only had one job in my entire
life working in a supermarket for one
year one day I walk into the supermarket
my manager was yelling at me calling me
names and I got so fed up with it I said
hey hey hey you and I walked out I went
home and my mom saw me and she asked me
oh how come you got off work early what
happened I said no I quit I don't want
to worked anymore it is stupid he's a
waste of time and my mom was so
concerned and so worried back then I was
making just minimum wage with that job
now do I recommend that you do this you
walk into your managers office your boss
often say hey I quit I'm gonna now start
a business I'm gonna do something else
no because I put my mom through hell I
put myself through hell looking back
what I'd have done that I'm not so sure
now I burn a ship I got that but what I
realize is most people are not quite
ready for that or they don't have their
tenacity to make it happen just quite
yet so if you're thinking about quitting
if you don't like what you do and you're
frustrated with the people you work with
or you don't like the job you're not
passionate about it what you need to do
is you need to have some kind of a skill
set first what I call high income skill
you may have a high income skill that
produces income for you before you quit
wouldn't be a smart idea because when
you quit today let me ask you this how
are gonna pay your bills I'm gonna get
income coming in how do you know the new
thing that you're doing is gonna work
how do you know you don't know so a much
smarter way to approach this is to
develop your skill first so when you
have a skill that you are selling you're
offering to the marketplace and you're
actually getting paid you're making
money and I believe the best way to do
this is when you're high income skill
makes you twice as much money
compared to your current job that you
have right now that when you can quit
then you can do this full-time
rule number 30 never give up give you
down right now if you're not where you
want to be right now if you're not
successful right now don't worry because
the signs of success are not obvious
what often looks like a failure on the
service is just a stepping stone towards
success so wherever you are in your
journey you need to realize your
adversity is your greatest advantage
your pain is your greatest tool because
happiness does not change you pain does
comfort does not move you adversity does
realize that your toughest times will
turn you into the toughest first
[Music]
what doesn't kill you will make you
stronger don't hide your pain don't run
away from your struggles use it turn
your pain into feel turn your failures
into motivation and never ever give up
rule number 31 don't use hope as a
strategy the most dangerous word that
you could use day-to-day is the work
hope hope this word keeps you poor think
about it when I talk to you entrepreneur
when I asked him so what exactly is your
marketing strategy they might say
something like well then my marketing
strategy is I build my business through
word-of-mouth the referrals and I always
reply you mean hope you see hope it's
not a strategy
most people they hope to grow their
business they hope to get referrals they
hope to generate more income they hope
to have more free time they hope to
start their business they hope they'll
get bank financing for the investments
they hope hope it's not a strategy you
see successful people we don't use hope
as a strategy because the minute you use
the word hope what you're saying is you
have no power you have no control over
the outcome why I hope it works I hope
this works out now it's one thing to say
hey I hope you like this video that's
okay but whenever you say I hope I when
you give away that responsibility you
also give away their power you have no
control you have no choice when you have
no choice when you have no control when
you have no power when you cannot decide
you cannot take action and you cannot
make that happen
rule number 32 know how to close Michael
Gerber from emails talks about this
most people they actually know
entrepreneurs they are technicians
suffering from an entrepreneurial
seizure meaning that they are very good
at the technical work
the thing but they don't understand how
the business works they do not know how
to sell see the number one skill that
you need as an entrepreneur as a
business owner is the ability to close
if you don't close sales you will not
bring in revenue and with no revenue you
don't have a business and yet most
people they get into business without
developing that skill set most people
don't know how to communicate fewer know
how to sell almost no one knows how to
close when you can close anyone at any
time it means that you have the ability
to generate revenue at any moment then
you can create revenue for your company
and that is the number one skill that
you need to make sure that your business
is successful rule number 33 be
confident successful people are
confident in their abilities you see the
two biggest enemies to success number
one self doubt number two fear of the
unknown we struggle with self doubt we
worry are we ready for this are we good
enough do we actually have what it takes
to succeed confidence is nothing more
than believing in yourself and believing
in yourself says nothing more than doing
the things that you once didn't believe
that you could do you see confidence
comes from competence it's easy to
believe in yourself when everyone
believes in you that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about
believing in yourself when you're not
ready believing yourself when no one
believes you believe in yourself when
everyone tells you that you cannot do it
then you cannot make it that you don't
have what it takes that is when you need
to develop that unshakable
self-confidence that believe that you
can do it and confidence is not the same
as arrogance the arrogance is thinking
that you above everybody else confidence
is knowing that no one is above you do
you feel confident enough in your own
abilities that you can do what it takes
are you willing to bet on yourself not
just words but
action how often you invest in yourself
are you willing to put everything you
have on the line for your goals and for
your dreams do you bet on yourself or do
you procrastinate do you hesitate
are you perfectionist do you suffer from
paralysis analysis
rule number 34 stop saying I can't I can
do it right I can i I don't have time oh
I can't afford it
these damn minute youth the word can't
your brain stops working stops looking
for solutions
the minute you sigh can't well that's it
I can't do it right it robs you of your
potential erupts you off the possibility
instead ask yourself how can I see when
people say to me why I can't start my
business or I can't develop the high
income skill or I can do that side
hustle oh I can't whatever I always tell
them does that mean that you don't want
to do it or does that mean you don't
know how to do it because we all have
the ability we can all do something if
we want you could you do it if you
really really really want to of course
you could so the question is is not I
can't
is either you don't want to and that's
perfectly fine then don't say I can't
just say I don't want you when your
friends ask you to go out it's just wow
you know I can tonight don't say I can't
just say you know what I've got other
commitments I don't want to go just tell
them I don't want to go this is not
something I want to do or maybe next
time write this side commit when you say
well I I can does that mean you don't
know how to do it because you could go
get the how - there's so much how to you
on the internet you could go find a way
you can you can take a program go to
native and learn from a mentor do is
something you have the ability so we
place that word can't with either how
can i or hey you know what I can do it I
can start that business I can learn that
skill I can learn from a mentor right I
can quit that job I can go on a vacation
you have got so much more
potential if you just believe in
yourself rule number 35 invest in
yourself first
mystic boys temple that you want to
start a Shopify store yes it kind of
doesn't cost you a lot but inventory
costs you money so you invest the last
few thousand dollars you have you go
all-in into this particular venture
hopefully that it will work my question
is what if it doesn't work what if the
product doesn't sell you put all your
life savings the little bit of money
that you have into it and then now what
what do you do where do you go from here
you see instead of doing that and then
putting all your eggs in one basket the
best thing you can do is start investing
in yourself first
invest in a skill set that you can
deliver to the marketplace in exchange
of money this dramatically lowers your
risk and then when that is working then
you can start your business rule number
36 embrace failures successful people
embrace failures do you embrace failures
or do you take failures personally you
see successful people they are
ridiculously positive about the future
they always speak positively about their
future where things are going as if it's
already happened even though there's no
way that it could happen they believe in
themselves
right they have positive expectations
about their future
Walt Disney was fired by a news editor
saying that he had no imagination and no
creativity Steven Spielberg was rejected
three times by film school before
getting his huge brick Colonel sander at
age of 56 got rejected a thousand times
for its recipe before a restaurant picks
it up you will notice the most
successful people in any field they are
usually the ones who have failed more
than anybody else you see the difference
between a successful person and everyone
else it's not a lack of strength it's
not a lack of knowledge it's a lack of
will wisdom Churchill said it best
success is going from failure to failure
without losing enthusiasm rule number 37
get more customers you want to get more
customers we all want more customers so
we can generate more revenue now it
depends on your business type you might
have a two-step process
meaning you may not get a customer
directly it may not be a direct sales
scenario it could be a two-step process
where you actually generate a lead maybe
generate a lead online and then you
convert that lead into a sell right it's
a two-step process so you have the lead
generation process and then you have the
conversion process it doesn't matter the
bottom line is that's what you focus on
that's what most entrepreneurs focus on
how do I get more customers the
challenge is if you have been in
business for any length of time that the
biggest payoff
sometimes the highest paid leverage
points that you have with the business
may not be getting more customers
because it causes a lot of money
you're quiet customers nowadays right
when you're running traffic when you're
doing any kind of advertising it costs a
lot of money to acquire their first
initial customer if you are a startup
yes then focus on getting customers
because you need customers to survive
but if you have been in business for a
while then I want you to consider some
of the other ways to increase your
revenue to grow your business rule
number 38 beyond the right path what I'm
doing right now right this path is it
gonna get me there
right if you are working at a minimum
weight job and you say you want to make
six figure a year you want to make you
know a quarter million dollars a year
well what are the chances of whatever
you're doing right now that would get
you there right and if not doesn't
matter what you do it's just that's the
wrong path because this path will never
get you there
rule number 39 find the right mentors
when you're watching someone's video
when you are following someone on social
media to me that is learning but that's
not mentorship mentorship is much more
intimate it's
much more special it's not just watching
someone passively so to me that there
are a lot of people that you can learn
from and I learned from a lot of people
over the years I mean I read so many
books and attend so many workshops and
and every lunch and dinner and and all
these people that are business people
that are interact with I learned from
them I hear their stories I hear their
struggles I hear about the best
practices however when it comes to
mentoring when it comes to having a
mentor I've only had really not up to
this point in my life three mentors in
my life
first one his name is Allen Alice my
very first mentor he taught me marketing
and copywriting right if you've watched
my video you know that second and it's
been my mentor since I was 20 in my
early 20s a me meet my opportunity right
to to to work for him for one year for
the next enough that Willie is working
for free but I learned a tremendous
amount from him and he gave me the
opportunity he he gave me the chance
right he believed in me when no one
believed in me
my second mentor and Pena the fifty
billion dollar man right you may have
seen him on on YouTube in fact I'm going
to visit him in in Scotland in a couple
months and he was here if you saw my
videos my interview with him so he's
been my mentor for more than a decade
now that's my second mentor and my third
mentor my new mentor mr. Duane doing
Clark and doing is a super super
successful man with with great values
and so that's my third mentor so really
I learned from everybody but when it
comes to selecting the right mentor I'm
very very selective I want to pick
someone that I could learn from for a
long time because most people when they
pick someone they see someone on YouTube
they see someone on you social media I
live with that person I wonder if I'm
the first person only from their person
well the problem with that approach is
think of it like martial art imagine you
learning you're taking a lesson a you
want to learn boxing this week next week
and you'll learn Brazilian jiu-jitsu and
then the week after you learn chinese
kungfu in it and then the next month you
learn something else you never get good
at it you never never get good at
anything because you're jumping from one
thing to another
make sense rule number 40 value yourself
good for free are you idiot [ __ ] well
that's one way to handle it when someone
asked us to work for free or can I pay
you later when you get results for them
but you can do it better than that you
can deal with their objection with
finesse he would of the day comment
below what's the word finesse it's like
Tai Chi you want to redirect don't fight
force with force redirect now remember I
used to get this objection quite a bit
when I was younger when I was just
starting out in my career right when I
don't have a track record then people
would ask me well Dan I would I would
pay you later when I get results on this
let's try this out or can you work for
free like what the my like a volunteer
right I'm a business person here so what
do you do when you get that kind of
objection so I'm gonna give you a couple
ways to handle this okay if you enjoy
this video give me a thumbs up remember
if you watch a lot of my other videos I
think you'll love this video as well so
here we go number one it's easier to
handle that with some kind of a metaphor
and some kind of a question right a
series of questions and seeing a picture
in their mind so when they say hey so
can you work for free you might say
something like hey mr. prospect let me
ask you a question here let's say you
want to buy a Porsche and you walk up to
a Porsche dealership and you say you
know what I want to take this Porsche
home and I'm gonna drive drive it for a
month and just see how I like it
right and then maybe come back and maybe
I'll pay you now if you are the the car
dealership you're the owner of this car
dealership what are you gonna say to
your prospect like that
well I'm gonna say no that's not how it
works oh no you're look it's stupid
idiot exactly right so that's a very
powerful way of using a metaphor to
handle it another way that I've used a
metaphor this kind of an interesting one
I would say hey mr. prospect let me ask
you a question have you ever eaten a
restaurant before yeah right so can you
walk up to the restaurant owner and say
hey you know what I'm gonna have I'm
gonna have the meal here and after them
you know I'm gonna go home I'm not gonna
pay I'm gonna go home and see how I do
in the bathroom let's see how much how I
like it what kind of power movement I
have and then when I come back I'll see
if I want to pay is it how it works no
that's not how it works at all right
like so there are different ways you can
handle in a in a in a sarcastic but also
firm and respectful way basically
telling them indirectly that you value
your time you're telling your prospect
that you value your skills and expertise
right now in the beginning maybe you do
have to do limited work pro bono to get
some experience that's not what I'm
talking about here we're talking about
closing and asking for money up front
right we're signing a deal we're signing
an agreement and we're trying to close a
deal right here or right now
rule number 41 change your environment I
always say that your willpower is never
as powerful as your environment a lot of
times maybe you want to change you want
to make a new decision you want to take
the leap of faith you want to do
something new but your environment is
not supportive of that the people around
you your family and friends they're not
supportive of your new goal your new
vision that you have for yourself or
maybe in terms of your environment where
you live in that is not supportive of
where you want to go so instead of
trying to fight with that I always say
change the environment change your
environment it's much more powerful
because your environment is more
powerful than your your willpower your
your discipline so what can you do to
structure and create that environment so
that it's easier for you to accomplish
whatever it is that you want to
accomplish
rule number 42 the
valuable skills instead of thinking now
we in we're no longer in a job economy
we're in a skill economy that you need
to think much more like a an independent
person with skillset that you offer it
could be two companies or two different
businesses or to the marketplace instead
of thinking or a job we provide for you
you need their flexibility right
developing what I call the high income
skill and I'm number of videos on
YouTube you can search on youtube
download high income skills you'll find
that so don't think arms in the job
economy that job economy their
credentials economy where a piece of
paper a piece of paper is not gonna
protect you when there's an economic
downturn a piece of paper is not gonna
prevent you from being laid off a piece
of paper it's not gonna pre friend that
your industry turn upside down and then
this massive change that's happening
it's not gonna protect anybody what no
one can take away is just you set the
value that you know you could provide to
people to the marketplace to companies
no one can take that away from you so
focus on skill not just a job rule
number 43 changed the way you think
about money people ask me all the time
Dan why they talk about money all the
time you see there's nothing wrong or
evil about money money is neutral
imagine if you enjoy talking about
basketball
Raptors NBA Canadian team right if you
enjoy playing basketball watching
basketball would you be ashamed to talk
about basketball with your friends your
buddies no you wouldn't
then why would you be ashamed talking
about money you see you have a story in
your mind right now about health about
success about life and also about money
you have a story in your mind right now
and guess who created those stories to
be your parents could be your relatives
it could be the people that you know
you're loved you're brought in sisters
your cousins it doesn't matter but you
picked up those stories from somewhere
when
member when you were a little kid the
horror story the scary story the spooky
story that the boogeyman hiding the
closet someone planted those thoughts in
your mind and someone planted those
thought about money in your mind as well
that it's hard to get money that rich
people are bad that you have to do
something bad to to make money and and
it's one thing to make money and it's
very difficult to keep money and if you
make the money and now you lose it then
you look really really stupid it is
simply not true the people who are
struggling with money they afraid to
talk about money and believe me they do
talk about money the difference is they
argue all the money your parents argue
over money do you argue over money with
your loved one your spouse your
boyfriend and girlfriend I remember one
of the few times in my life that I saw
my mom cried was because we ran out of
money so remember money secret number
one money moves to those who are not
afraid to talk about it rule number 44
hold yourself accountable most of us
live up to other people's expectations
we don't want to disappoint other people
so let's use that don't just rely on
yourself disciplined let's say you have
a goal instead of just keeping that to
yourself and say I'm gonna work on there
I'm gonna work on that and when I get
there then I'm gonna tell other people
about it know do the opposite do what I
do tell the whole word about it
declare to the whole world this is who I
am this is what I'm gonna do this is who
I want to be these are my goals and you
tell the whole freakin word about it
the world will hold you accountable just
like my youtube channel I declared in
the beginning I'm gonna hit a hundred
thousand subscribers with it that at the
clear the world we're gonna hit a
million subscribers by the end of 2018
we did that now we've declared the word
we're gonna hit ten million subs guess
what we're gonna do that I don't hide to
myself and say oh I'm just keep it to
myself
these are this is my goal no I'm gonna
tell
we're gonna do it we're gonna do an eye
we're gonna do it together it's the same
thing rule number 45 do what you love
this this village and the government
wants to develop in this village so they
send some of the top agents to talk to
the chief of this village and these
agents they showed up to talk to the
chief and say hey chief we are planning
to spend millions and millions of
dollars building infrastructure helping
you to develop this village and achieve
it's like okay so what are you planning
to do the agents are saying you know
what chief is what we're gonna do we are
going to have some buses we're gonna
send a lot of buses to your village the
achieve it's like okay so why do we need
buses well we're gonna have all these
buses we're gonna have you we're gonna
educate you we're gonna bring your
people and then we're gonna bring them
to a school the chief is asking well why
do we want to go to school the agents
are saying well when you go to school
you're gonna study different subjects
and topics and so that you could get a a
diploma or a degree the chief is like
okay so what happens after we get the
degree and the diploma oh then you'll be
able to graduate you're gonna be able to
find a safe secure job and achieve it's
like okay so why do you want to save the
qhr oh come on chief when you have the
safe secure job then you're gonna be
able to make some money you make some
money then you're gonna you can have
kids your people are gonna have kids and
then you can get a house okay so and
then the chief cycle Canada and then
what oh then you get a house and you put
aside some some money and then you work
many many many years until you're 65 and
guess what chief and you can't wait
tired and the chief it's like okay then
what happens after what time what do you
mean what happens after we time it after
what time you can do whatever you want
you can go fishing you can spend time
with your family you can go hunting you
can do whatever you want
the chief looks at the agents and saying
I'm doing there right now I'm fishing
and hunting and spending time with my
family right now
why didn't go through all this process
the moral of the story is this that
sometimes we are chasing we're so
focusing on the goals and we sometimes
forget
why do we want those things in the first
place it's what I believe is a very
important I want to share with you it's
not just how much money you make is how
you make the money knowing that money is
just a vehicle is a means to an end at
the end of a what is it that you're
after
rule number 46 stop using the word try
I'll try to do something well I tried
see when you use the word try the minute
you use that word you are setting
yourself up for failure you're giving
yourself a way out when something
doesn't work out well you know I try I
try my best I try to call you man right
I try do this with me I want you if
you're sitting down if you're standing
up you doing something you're watching
me right now listen to me I want you to
try to walk a step forward try to walk a
step take a step no no I didn't say walk
a step
I said try to walk a step towards me go
ahead no I didn't say move a step I said
try try to move no I did not say move a
step I said try to move a step you see
the state of trying doesn't exist it is
a made a [ __ ] story that we created
in our own minds the state of try it
doesn't exist either you do or you don't
there is no such thing either you move
on you can take a step forward or you
don't take a step forward there is no
try try means nothing it means nothing
happens so eliminate that word from your
vocabulary
rule number 47 take action now one of
the things I teach all my students who
are learning closing from me very simple
I teach them a roleplay a day keeps
property away right every single day you
spend at least invest at least one hour
role play and honing your skills is
there simple it's an integration it's
not a well today I don't feel like a
little role play or
I'll do it tomorrow and then you
procrastinate and you don't do it for a
week and then guilt kicks in oh I should
have done there but I didn't do it now
if I do it it's kind of too late that
looks stupid in front of the people is
all this BS if in your mind versus hey
you know why we do an hour day and now
they will play period that's it there's
no thinking I don't want you to think
about it I don't want you to hesitate I
don't even want you to do it just
integrate it into your life
every single day I'm going to do an hour
wall play period if you want to improve
your closing skill you see it takes all
the decisions making out out of your
thoughts all these Spears in your in
your mind take that away and just do
that
remember 48 expand if you're serving a
local market if you are making money
generate income from just working with
and serving people in your city expand
that so instead of focusing a local
market how can you take what you do an
offer to a more global market so when
this economic downturn in your country
and I know our friends in you know over
the world in your country or in your
city you're not depending on it when you
are serving people in so many different
countries right because usually when
there's like an economic downturn in
this country this is booming right if
this there's a problem with this country
right and this is booming so instead of
focusing on a local market serve a
global market
rule number 49 don't quit have you had
more ones in your life when you feel
like you just want to give up then no
one is coming to help you no one is
coming to rescue you then you've tried
everything you possibly could to solve
the problem that's in front of you
and just feel like quitting I've had
many many of those moments in my life
and in my career as an entrepreneur I
faced various challenges competitions
problems on a day-to-day basis and there
many times in my life that I felt maybe
I couldn't solve this problem maybe I
couldn't overcome this maybe I should
just quit I'm not gonna give you some
rah-rah motivational talk and say hey
just don't give up just hang in there
just don't give up what I am gonna do is
to share with you some of the things
I've learned when I've gone through a
lot of ups and downs in my business
career to get to where I am today that
what do you do when you feel like you
want to quit when you feel like quitting
what do you do you see whatever that's
in front of you whatever obstacle that's
in front of you right now and you feel
like you have done everything you
possibly could that yes I have tried
everything to overcome this my question
to you is have you tried everything have
you talked to enough people have you
read all the books that you could on
this topic that you seek mentorship have
you seek help have you done everything
you possibly could have you taken all
the actions that you possibly could to
overcome this have you my guess is
probably not
because if you have you would have
already gotten the results you see it's
never a matter of lack of resources
it's always a lack of resource fulness
that you're not created enough that we
are not created enough that we don't
think outside the box enough and
sometimes when you get so close so close
to your goal a lot of us we just give up
we quit when we are disclosed to
achieving that goal you see success is
on the razor's edge of
when you think it couldn't get any worse
when you think it couldn't be worse than
what you're going through right now when
you think it couldn't be any tougher
that's when breaks do happens sometimes
in life you break down before you break
through and rule number 50 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is have
fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank me later
[Music]
aigoo today in room now I have a special
bonus tip from Dan on how to not follow
fake gurus that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what do you need to stop saying I can't
- number two whose opinions do you need
to stop caring about and number three
what are the excuses that you need to
stop making for yourself and if you like
this video and you're going to take
action give me a hashtag believe down
the comments as well following fake
gurus is a great thing about the
internet is there's so much information
out there the sad thing about the
Internet is that nowadays everyone is an
expert everyone it's a guru they are
telling you to do this and don't do that
everyone and their brother-in-law in the
dog it's got an e-commerce store right
now and they're telling you that hey
just follow my system and you'll live
the life of your dreams my question to
you is if you ask yourself if you think
critically what qualifies them to give
you advice most of these so-called
experts they come and go I've seen it
for so many years right see the name the
game is not getting rich the name of the
game is staying rich most of these
so-called gurus are experts they're kind
of fly-by-night they do not last it's
like fireworks a lot of noise and later
on nowhere to be found
isn't it true so if you notice who you
learn from it's much more important of
what you learned are they truly proven
other models proven to work in different
market conditions and in different
circumstances and if you really dig DB
what do you think about it they will
eliminate 99% of them and these gurus
are telling you trends that might
disappear overnight
then you're building your future
on quicksand instead of on a solid
foundation so ask yourself are these
trends going to be around one year two
year three years five years ten years
from now hi this is Dan Locke if you're
a fan of Evans work if you want to know
exactly how the model my success I want
to invite you to join me for a special
online training all you have to do is
click on a link below you can join me
for absolutely no charge so click a link
below and I will see you in class if you
want more Dan lock check out the other
top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
the more I try to chase them on I want
to make the money I want to make the
money then you can see these people
they're so desperate they don't make
money you don't make money if your life
stinks it's your fault